avec la multiplication des attentats et
des complots terroristes
on en parle de plus en plus mais qu'est
ce que l'état islamique
il s'agit en fait d'une entité créée en
2006 en irak
c'est un mouvement djihadiste salafiste
c'est à dire que c'est un mouvement qui
veut imposer partout où il passe
l'interprétation la plus radicale du
coran mais aussi imposer la loi la plus
brutale qui soit la charia le chef du
groupe armé est à islamique s'appelle
abou al bagdadi il a déjà été fait
prisonnier par les américains il a
milité au sein d'al-qaïda et plus tard
il a décidé de focaliser tous ses
efforts avec l'étendue l'expansion de
l'état islamique
aujourd'hui ce groupe est présent bien
sûr surtout en irak et en syrie où il
règne sur un territoire d'environ 10
millions de personnes mais également au
liban en afghanistan en algérie au
pakistan en egypte en libye bref de plus
en plus son emprise s'étend aujourd'hui
il est une fois de plus basée à mossoul
en irak ainsi qu'à raqqa en syrie une
date importante à retenir pour l'état
islamique c'est le 29 juin 2014
c'est la date à laquelle abou al bagdadi
c'est en quelque sorte autoproclamé
successeur de mahomet mais surtout à
proclamer le califat un espèce de
vestiges de l'empiré ottoman et qu'il
veut étendre depuis l'afrique du nord
jusqu'à l'asie centrale
l'état islamique c'est un groupe qui est
en fait le plus riche en terme de groupe
terroriste aujourd'hui sur la planète
selon les chiffres de 2014 il aura
amassé une fortune de trois milliards de
dollars principalement lorsqu'ils ont
saisi les champs pétrolifères et gaziers
par exemple aujourd'hui chaque jour
l'état islamique collecte environ 2
millions de dollars grâce à la vente de
pétrole mais l'état islamique est aussi
présent dans l'agriculture le ciment et
surtout à amasser de l'argent en pillant
les banques en pratiquant la vente
d'esclaves en demandant des rançons et
au fur et à mesure a également amassé un
arsenal impressionnant d'armes des armes
qui ont d'ailleurs principalement été
laissées par les différents pays qui
sont passés par l'irak
entendez par là surtout de l'armement
américain
le coût permettent à islamique on n'a
pas fini d'en parler